[Music]
you
hello so we are back again today with a
section on attention
a brief review of what we have done up
till now in attention so in the previous
classes we looked at what is attention
and the various factors which go ahead
and define how attentional really works
or - so specifically we looked at this
brain process or this mental process
called attention how it goes ahead and
distributes the cognitive energy sources
which is available and how attention is
equivalent to mental concentration we
also looked at a method of going ahead
and performing attentional studies and
in that we saw a brilliant experiment by
Jerry which is called the dichotic
listening task the reason why this
experiment was designed was because
attentional studies are difficult to
carry out and so after defining what
sherry looked into or what share his
experiment brought out it the common
result from the study was that those
stimuli which we focused our attention
to metal concentration - those what
processed but those stabilized to which
we were not putting any mint metal
concentration from the unattended year
they were not processed but amazingly
the study did bring out this fact that
some physical features of messages from
the unintended year was also processed
now Marie came up and gave
counterexample or basically a problem
with the sherry study which was the
cocktail party effect and threw his
cocktail party effect phenomena he
showed that attention even if we are not
paying attention to some stimuli they
passed the threshold so they are
registered on to our attentional system
so working on this assumption that even
if we are not paying attention to some
civilized they are processed several
theories were developed and so the first
theory was the filter theory which
explained attention as filter and the
filter works on physical properties of
the incoming stimuli from perception and
so they find that only those events to
which we perceive our attention gets
passed out and all other stimuli to
which we would focus our attention gets
excluded at the attentional filter and
at Richmond added a new theory into this
whole idea of attention she div defined
or showed that those stimuli which which
were not processed or which were at the
unattended year were actually it's it's
not that they were not processed the
volume we're toned down they were
attenuated and through a clever
experiment she showed that people's
attention actually work as all-or-none
kind of a phenomena and her task was the
yes switching tasks so basically on a
tradesman showed that it's not that the
unattended here the information from the
unattended ear doesn't get processed
they are toned down and so if need be or
the threshold of the incoming message is
such that it is it is low they to get
processed and so an additional theory a
new theory was also proposed which is
called a late selection theory which
argued against the filter theory saying
that the bottleneck or the filter that
we talked about in terms of processing
of incoming messages doesn't exist at
the very beginning of a message but at
the late part of a message which
basically means that most messages are
processed till the meaning level till a
basic meaning level in addition to this
we had the multimodal theory and
the theory which talks about the stages
of processing of any stimuli through the
attentional filter and so the model
Theory defines that there are three
stage of processing or there are three
attentional filters which exist and
depending on at which stage two messages
appear different to to the cognitive
system that is the point at which the
filter is applied so at the first level
what happens is two messages are
differentiated on in terms of the
phonology I'm sorry not the phonology
but in in terms of the basic physical
properties like what is the tone of fate
how intense it is and so on and so forth
and the second level it is the semantics
or the phonology and semantics of the
message which basically goes ahead and
designs the filter or is responsible for
filtration and then there is a third
stage if the messages are same in terms
of a basic meaning and and the basic
physical properties a third level or
higher dimensional level is is chosen
for distinguishing two messages and this
dimension uses both the physical
properties phonological properties and
the semantic properties of the message
so all three are considered and
differentiations of messages are done so
this is about the attentional theory now
in addition to this we also looked at
something called automation the question
was whether if we do enough of practice
can we go ahead and make a task
automatic which basically means that it
requires lesser and lesser attention and
so more attention is available or more
resources are available for putting
ourselves to or doing some other work
and we define certain limits to it we
define certain features of how
preferences of attention really work and
what is the basic factors which govern
this autumn a city that we are talking
about and in one of the interesting
examples that we took in in the last
class physically in the last class was
the Stroop desk so we saw that if enough
practice is done I finished a fitness
practice is applied attention can be
made automatic and so just the slides
that you're seeing right now it is the
last sight from the last class which
shows that with enough practice autumn
ization happens so in today's class what
we are going to see is the optimization
how does this automation really work
this automation of attention really
works and how is it helpful I will also
look at what is the difference between
an automatic system and automatic
processing of message and a control
transfer processing of message so
attentional systems how our attentional
system two systems which use an
automatic processing in a control
processing how are they different and
what are the factors governing them in
addition to it we'll also look at some
of the examples or some of the good
outgrowth of this attentional study why
not growth that we look into is
something called the psychological
refractive period so let's continue with
a discussion of automatic of attention
so a basic question which is in front of
us right now is what does it mean to
perform a task automatically
authorization of task performance what
is the meaning of that particular thing
and an answer was given by Snyder and
Posner in 1975 and what they said was
attentional processing is automatic or
there is an automation of attentional
process only when it fulfils any process
fulfills three different things or three
different features the first is that the
task that is at hand the task which is
getting process must occur with
and intention which means that an task
is said to be getting processed
automatically with automatic attentional
systems with the help of automatic as
natural systems
it requires no intention at all so as
soon as we develop an intention as soon
as we think of a task and we develop an
intention to do that particular task
then this particular task doesn't become
automatic so Intermatic task processing
requires no intention and I'll give an
example to see how this optimization
really works so many a times in your
everyday routine you would have seen
that the part from your University or
the part from the place of your work to
your home is somewhat automatically
remembered to you and so at time what
happens is when some other job for some
other task is getting into your head for
example some other work-related or
university related problem is bugging
you in some way
if that that is what is happening then
what would happen is in those times you
you will automatically drive towards or
automatically move towards your home and
this movements instance you the part
between your home and your work is so
well learned that if another task is
taking up your attention you don't even
realize that you had to go to the market
but then what has happened is since the
your attentional capacity of mental
resources were exerted we're engaged
somewhere else you automatically turn
towards your home so which basically
means that turning towards the act of
turning towards your home is without
intention and that is why it is an
automatic process because you didn't
decide to go towards your home you were
deciding to go somewhere else but since
the mental effort the attentional
processes were not available and so
since this task is too practiced this
way from your home to the University or
unis to your home is so well practice so
that that unintentionally there without
an intention you move towards your path
because this is what you
every day now the second process or the
second feature that should be involved
in an automatic processing or automatic
processing of tasks is something called
conscious without the task should happen
without conscious awareness so if you
make in mind or if you keep in mind the
fact that I have to do a particular task
and you do it with that formal
intervention consciously which means
that you remind yourself somehow they'll
do this task then doing that task they
will require attention and will not be
automatic example in our like in the one
plot that I just gave to you where you
move from the since your attention is so
occupied you move from your University
to the home and you in in that path you
automatically go towards your home in
that particular example the act of
moving or taking the turn which which
separates the way to the market to the
way from the way to the home the act of
turning towards your home is without
conscious awareness so you have not
decided it you have not form an
intention and it is without conscious
awareness you never planned it before
and so it is automatic in nature and the
third thing is that these tasks should
not be or should not have any kind of
interference from other mental activity
the meaning of this is that if another
mental activity which is similar to the
automatic task visit to the task which
has requires automatic processing or
which goes to automatic processing if
they are same what would happen is the
task will no more be automatic so in our
example since our problem our university
problem has engaged you in certain way
and it has nothing to do with motor
movement it has nothing to do with
thinking about going home or anything
related to you going to home this other
task which you are thinking takes up a
lot of your mental activity a lot of
your mental resources and this mental
activity is very different from the
walking task or writing or whatever way
you communicate from universe with the
home and so since the
very different in nature the second task
of in evidently
of unintentionally moving towards your
home or taking the turn towards your
home becomes automatic in nature so
basically summing it up any automatic
tasks should have three features into it
it should be done it shouldn't be done
with with an intention it should not
have a conscious awareness behind it
which basically means that you should
not be consciously doing it and the
third is that this task should not be
interfered with any mental activity
should a mental activity interfere with
it
it the task will not be becoming
automatic or the start a task would not
become automatic so next let's take a
look at what what does it mean to have a
controlled process tasks an automatic
process task what I mean by here is that
those tasks which require at a control
processing attentional processing and
those tasks which require onion
unintentional processing or intentional
processing which are automatic in nature
what is the difference between tasks
like this now so one of the interesting
things is before discussing this is
something called attentional capture we
will come to that in a moment so look at
the display in front of you now in this
display if I asked you to find out the
one item which doesn't belong to the
display your answer is very quick that
tree is the word or tree is the letter
which pops out or which is not
equivalent to what the display is and so
this is called the pop-up phenomena and
this becomes this is an automatic
phenomena so those but if I ask you to
find out the specific letter for example
say the letter I or let us see it will
take more time so three throws out
itself to you and so it becomes
automatic
and whereas searching for I or C in this
display is a more controlled task
because it will require you to go ahead
and basically do control processing
attentional processing of
in this letter so distinguishing this
how this control and automatic
processing works and what are the
factors which control it Snyder's
Schneider and Shiffrin in 1977 designed
a very ingenious experiment to test
whether or what are the factors which
control or which go ahead and define an
attentional and uh non-intentional
processing so basically it's a search
letter it's a it's a search task and the
search is either of a letter or of a
digit in a frame so it's a very simple
task a certain target is given and you
have to search this target in a
particular frame now there are two
different versions of this particular
task one is called one version is called
the varied mapping version and the other
is called the consistent mapping version
of this task so what is the task like
the task has a certain target so these
in the varied mapping version of it you
would have targets as both letters or a
digit or a letter as a target so you can
have l1 three-peat as a target whereas
in the consistent version of the task
you either have letters or you have
digits so you can either you have one
two four six as a target because this is
what you need to search in the frame so
this is called the memory set this is
what subjects have to commit to memory
and then there is a frame that you have
to search these targets
so one difference between Maryland and
consistent mapping is that in varied
mapping we could have both numbers and
letters as in the memory set the set for
to which you need to compare whereas in
the consistent mapping either have
numbers or you have letters then you
have a display like this which is called
the frame and what you need to do is you
need to search this in the frame so in
the very condition you would have either
letters or numbers on to the frame of
such though so what you need to do is to
find out whether this is present in this
frame or not so it could the memory set
could be one letter it could be two
letter could be chill it depending on
different versions of the task it could
be anything and the task is to search
whether this memory set is present in
this frame or not the difference is I
also go along telling you the
differences between two versions the
task in the varied version you have
either letters or digits that need to be
searched where is in the consistent for
a version you all only have either
letters or digits similarly in the frame
set also there is a difference the
difference here is that in the case of
varied mapping version the search in the
frame set what you are searching in the
frame the frame could also have both
letters and digits whereas in the
consistent were a version if I am
searching for numbers or if I am
searching for digits you only have
digits which are reported here another
interesting thing or another change
which distinguishes these two versions
of the task is that in this version in
the varied version one of these letters
one of these item and the memory set
could become a distractor in to the next
frame for example I have P here in the
memory set this P can very well appear
in our different memory set and so what
would happen is since P is available
here now it is a target in this case
these this P because the next search
item is q3 to 8 and so in this case Q is
the letter here and P which has been
used previously in this memory set which
was an item of the memory Novica now is
a present here with distractor whereas
this is not true for the varied and the
consistent mapping of it so three
differences first of all what happens is
that memory set there is a difference in
terms of memory set memory set in the
varied version could be both letters and
numbers whereas in the consistent
version it is either letters and numbers
second the frame set could have both
letters and numbers in the varied
condition whereas in the consistent
condition it will either be letters or
it will either be numbers both is not
true and third that one item or any item
from the memory set can become a
distractor in the next frame in the next
trial of the task whereas each trial is
new or each new each new presentation of
frame is actually new it has nothing
from the older memory set so an
experiment was done like this and people
were supposed to find out this or
basically go ahead and tell whether this
particular memory said is present in
this frame or not wearing these three
other factors were varied in addition to
whatever we have discussed here so one
factor which were varied was called the
frame size size of the frame so
basically how many letters do appear
here so frame size is equivalent to how
many letters or how many digits are
appearing in the frame the second thing
that was there is for how long so frame
size and then frame time how long these
frames were presented so you see a
target and the frame is shown to you
and so the length of time for which the
frame was presented to you so it was a
fast frame presentation or a slow frame
presentation and the third thing was the
memory set itself so how many letters
were present in the memory said that you
need to search it could be one it could
be two it could be four so depending on
and four was the highest number which
was there so I have displayed the
highest number it could also be just one
letter one that you need to search so
these three factors were actually used
and this kind of a search task was
design the results were very interesting
so there is a good amount of work or
there is a good amount of results which
are came out of the study and it
proposed some of the very good outputs
in cognitive psychology and I refer you
I'll basically suggest you to read this
Snyder and schriften experiments show
SCH n I de R and s hifi1609 so let's
focus on to some of the most consistent
resources the study in through this
study we are trying to see how does
consistent mapping or thus controlled
sorry
how does control processing and at an
automatic processing work so let's look
at the the results which are akin to
these two problems so what are the
results then and so the results that we
got or the results that these
psychologists got to us in the varied
condition all three factors right the
frame time the frame size and the memory
set had a role to play in to how fast
you are actually passing now if you look
into it it's actually the consistent
mapping is representing something called
automatic processing and varied mapping
requires something called control
processing because what could happen is
that the memory suit could maybe
it could have numbers and letters growth
and similarly the frame put had numbers
and letters so you need more attentional
system to process and so the results
suggested that the varied mapping
condition all three factors actually
went ahead and showed their effects on
two results whereas in the consistent
mapping condition only you have guessed
correct it is the frame nine how much
time the frame was present because one
of the things is that is encoding so if
a stimulus is not encoded at all control
processing cannot take place so since it
is letters verifying letters and numbers
verifying numbers the only factor the
only variable which went ahead and and
and affected or this consistent mapping
paradigm was the frame time whereas
inconsistent in the result for very
varied mapping condition you have the
frame size the frame time as well as the
memory set of how many letters are being
searched all three of them made their
marks into it or made their effects or
showed their effects on to this search
process so
the thing is attentional is a cognitive
capacity and just before attention to
start or part of attention also works in
terms of perception so we seen a
sectional perception and it is a good
time to ask the question what role does
attention play in perception and this is
the exact question which was asked by
enna tradesmen she asks the role of
attention in autumn a city of attention
of control an automatic attention that
plays in perception and so what very
briefly what the theory says is that
attention has a lot of role to play in
perception and what is it Arnett has
been investigated through the future
integration model and what we find out
is that any perception to take place has
two stages so perception is basically a
two-stage process it starts so this is a
bottom-up process it starts this way in
stage one what happens is it's called
the pre-attentive stage and in stage one
what really happens is that the physical
features of a stimulus that is incoming
into perception into perceptual system
into the perceptual module for
processing those basic features are
integrated together and so we register
features of object color and shape into
the creativity stage so perception is a
two-part process because attention plays
a role into it in the first part of
perception the basic features of any
stimulus are recorded or map or
integrated and then there is a attentive
stage a second stage so first stage
basic features are integrated together
or a whole is combined through various
features of them all the incoming
stimuli
here attention allows to glue the
features together so basically this is
as you can see there is a curvature
depth motion orientation color these are
the physical features and so these
features this is the pre-attentive stage
in
these features are actually integrated
together under the attentional spotlight
to discuss the attentional spotlight
paradigm and only this attentional
spotlight only after this is integrated
together here does the attentive stage
works through which a meaning is
generated to object perception and
object recognition is takes place at the
attentive stage so think of it in this
way as you as we see something as soon
as we see something initially in the
first stage things like color shape
texture gradient this kind of things are
available to us but if we if that
particular image or if whatever we are
seeing is available more time they are
glued together to make a meaning which
basically suggests that if something is
presented to very fast people will be
able to tell the physical features but
may not be able to tell what does the
thing mean or what is the object in
terms of our recognition and this
particular feature where if a stimulus
is presented very fast so that the
attentional stage so that the attenti
stage is somehow hindered people report
something called illusory correlation so
if if a stimulus if two features of a
stimulus is present it very fast
what really happens is the at the
pre-attentive stage automatic stage
recognizes the features of the stimulus
and so late but the gluing is not
correct you don't know what is what
think of it in this way if I quickly
show you four different cars in four
different colors in four different model
when I show you for one thousandth of a
second kind of for one hundredth of a
second kind of display and very quickly
I so I show you this and very quickly I
take it away and then ask you what do
you actually see in terms of tell me the
colors of the car tell me the models of
the car and also tell me which car was
rich model amazing you will find out
that you could tell me the color of the
car you could also tell me how the model
looked like because the model is
basically the model of
car is displayed by the logo of the car
so you can perceive the features of the
logo or the the image of the logo and so
you can tell me what car was present so
you could go ahead and tell me that the
blue car was present and in a car which
is Honda I was present because Honda has
a logo specific kind of a logo a Maruti
was present but if it is very fast what
would happen is you will mix up
everything and so you tend to tell me
that a blue molecules present whereas
the truth is that of course a blue car
was present of course a marque was
present but what happened is they were
not the same and this is what is called
a diversity correlation so tradesmen in
scheme 8th 1982 interesting study showed
that when attention is diverted or
overloaded participant makes something
called illusory correlation so if I give
you more than one job to do is in the
previous example as I defined if I give
you two job for example if I ask you
very simple questions of what was the
car color or what was the car model it
is an easy answer but when I mix them
together which model which car and which
color then the problem becomes more and
since it was presented for very very
brief period of time this irizarry
correlations or do happen so in terms of
in terms of an attachment this kind of
display was used knowing the first
display it's very easy because people
were asked to report an S right just a
letter S or or a particular color of or
double X or s or a tea so tell me those
letters which appear in the pink color
or tell me those letters which are
different than the display so most of
the most of the display as X's and T's
and s is the only one which is different
and so this kind of questions can be
very easily answered and this requires
automatic nearly automatic processing or
no attention at all because this pops up
and this is what is call attention of
capture what happens is that this
particular thing pops up it moves
now I've seen these websites several
websites which are there when you visit
a website what really happens is that
certain things keep moving and the
bottom are certain things quickly change
color and they catch your attention but
other things don't basically it is a
tsunami nough like this what happens is
that this with the very idea that it is
different in terms of shape and shape is
a very basic feature at the pre
attentive stage itself these get
captures but look at this day number two
now in display number two if I ask you
to find an X which is green in color so
I'll ask you to find a letter which is
of different color so a letter in a
color so not two features to be looked
at a different color has to be looked at
on a different letter has to be looked
at any of these displays per represented
very fast you can of course see two
colors and a different color is there
and a different name is there so which
is the digit which is in a different
color two features required when two
features required this becomes more of a
controlled processing so when more than
one because here what would happen is if
an illusionary correlation can happen
I'll tell you how how it happens
what happens is if this display is
presented very fast then you tend to say
yes a tea with a green color was there
right or if it is very very fast you
would see a V because it looks more or
less like this but then what really
happens is that if two features are are
asked a letter with a different color
and a different image is what you need
to find out if that is what you need to
do then a problem exists because there
are two features that you are looking
into and so the two piece features has
to be somehow combined single feature
presentation or signal single feature
identifications happens in the
creativity stage whereas this multiple
feature comparison and object
recognition require that interface and
so at the attentive face so this this
particular task requires the control
processing or attentive face to really
work and this requires the automatic
phase so the answer to the question of
how perception or tension affects
perception is that if paths are
automatic in nature or tasks require a
very physical features basic physical
features for identification they are or
nearly
automatic but if tasks have were
stimulus tasks have more features and
they require some more processing then
attention comes into play and so
attentional systems are needed so very
simple tasks don't require attention or
they are more or less automatic in
nature
a related feature is something called
attentional capture that thing they were
discussing in in in in the studies
before so visual search tasks they if
they use this or they have this pop-up
phenomena remember the example that I
gave you in websites there are certain
features there are certain animations
out there which quickly change color and
form and so they capture your attention
and this is called the pop-up phenomena
or papad phenomena and so experimental
psychologists call this phenomena as
attentional capture which means that
they mean to imply a stimuli that cause
an involuntary shift in attention so
these features are such that they
somehow threw themselves out of the
stimulus set which is in a work and they
desire your attention or they move out
of of the display catching your
attention psychologists have defined
attentional capture to be a bottom-up
process driven entirely or almost by
properties of the stimulus rather than
perceivable so it is basically it it is
a stimulus feature which makes something
pop out but it has nothing to do with
whether the observer has anything to do
with it where the person perceiving has
anything to do with it so if we look
into here if I give you a second to look
into here and tell me what is the
problem so most of you would point out
that this is not possible from 1840 to
2007 is something which is wrong and
this captures our attention most
people's attention it should be 1942 and
this is an error so basically this
system which pops out which says that
which somehow tells you that this long
somebody cannot leave that is what what
on attentional capture so an interesting
experiment was done with attentional
capture so what was this experiment
basically this experiment had this kind
of circles six or seven circles and at
the center of these circles you had the
number eight returned on to them and all
these circles were gray in color so this
kind of circle was then people were
asked to look into this circle and so at
certain predefined time all but one
circle remember all of these are gray
colored circles with the letter 8 into
it so at a predefined time let's say
after 1 second or after 5 seconds all
but one circle they change their color
so most of the circus change the color
from gray to red and so the inside
became C right so one circle let's say
this circle remained gray and this
circle all these circles became red and
so the ins and also the inside of the
circus changed from A to C now the
question was asked that first of all
tell me which of the circles didn't
change the color that thing and what is
written inside that circle not unknown
to the observer an extra red circle
appeared either here or somewhere in the
display so an extra circle came up into
this display and popped up from some
from somewhere and the task is taxing
because people have to find out how many
circles change color which ones which
was the one which didn't change color
and which what is the shift in terms of
letters and so when a display like this
was used and a sudden letter a certain
new circle with red circle appears
somewhere in this display with with C
written on it or
something written on it you would what
is the result you would assume most
people almost 85% people actually saw
the red circle appearing what happened
is that irrespective of the fact that
people had their attentional blocked up
by the task itself but this circle
suddenly appearing somewhere other than
this this particular slot it captured
their attention so a red circle in the
middle or somewhere here there it
captured the attention and this is what
is called attentional capture think of
it in terms of those websites those
things which capture your attention
things which come out or it come out
because they have that the stimulus the
those things or those events has certain
features they jump out of the of the
screen or jump out of any environment on
to you and with the fact that you have
nothing to do with it you are not
expecting it so kind of an unexpected
event and so this is what this
particular theory of attentional capture
basically goes ahead and tells us now
so based on what we have learned up till
now Gordon Logan and Joseph E Turton
they combined this idea of what
attention is when it becomes automatic
when it becomes control what are the
factors combined all these two things
together to give and auto attentional
hypothesis of attention now what is this
hypothesis this hypothesis is very
simple nature what it says is that
attention is only required at the
practice phase of any task and so as
soon as you have started practicing as
soon as you have enough practice that
task becomes automatic but if something
changes in in the stimuli in which it is
being presented again a practice is
required or the fact that
so basically attentional hypothesis of
atomization stage that attention is
needed just during the practice here is
the fat ask and determines what gets
laundering
practice and attention also determines
what will be remembered from practice so
simply say it says that basically
learning is a by-product of attention
but if something else changes into the
stimuli then what happens is you don't
learn it and so you need a attentional
stage to further follow so just at the
time of learning a task you need
attention and once you have learned it
enough the task somehow becomes
automatic it is basically what
experience would suggest so if you are a
tennis player at the initial hours you
need all kind of attention to learn what
is the backend what is the foreign hand
what is your serve and so on and so
forth and how to do the footwork in
these kind of things but once you know
this task very well playing tennis is
almost automatic in nature and then
unless something changes and they did a
very good experiment to prove that it is
practice that require this kind of
attention so they use something called
they had associate learning to prove
that this kind of autumn ization
hypothesis appears which means that
practice requires autumn ization and
after practice practice requires a
tangent sorry and after that the task
becomes automatic so they use this kind
of a pair associate tasks in their task
what they had they had this kind of
pairs so you had the word steel which is
attached to a word let's see
Canada right and this kind of pairs were
presented to people and so people had to
learn this kind of a task so this kind
of pair associate has to be learned and
in one version of the task this steel
was never paired to any other word and
so they were very specific in terms of
this in another version of the task the
word steel was sometimes paired to
Canada whereas sometimes it was Pat -
let's say broke only another word which
is there now in this case you see that
performance has increased and tasks
become automatic or the process
thing becomes automatic since steel on
Canada are related only one so if I do a
retrieval of this task it is more or
less automatic but in this case we're
still sometimes appear with Canada the
task is paired associated to most para
to associate tasks required to learn
both the pair's and actually travel you
are given the Q this is the Q so in this
case steel is called the Q and you when
I say the Q steel the person who's
responding the person who's retrieving
back has to tell me the target so Canada
here is called the target and the person
has to the person who's responsible
Canada so this is the kind of job so
when steel is specifically related to
Canada the performance becomes rather
automatic and so what happens is that
only during the practice of it you need
to put more focus and so task learning
is very fast but in terms when it is in
the second case when steel is related to
Canada somehow another terms in another
version of its steel is also related to
broccoli when I stay steel the
performance doesn't become automatic and
so you have to actually think use your
brain and use more attention to come up
with the particular answer to the
question also it was shown that even if
one part of this pad associate learning
if the Q was colored in some way if the
Q was green in color and this was right
in color even in those cases this
learning was very slow and it was not
automatic it required a lot of attention
which means that failures were huge it
took more time corresponding so this is
more faster this is more slower and even
changing one part of this the Q part of
it required people more time so
basically this task somehow this
experiment goes ahead and proves that
only during practice you need attention
whereas once the practice is over
it is automation or the automatic
processing starts happening you don't
need attention that much but only in
those cases
where
things changed from the original display
if something is changing the original
display is some form of changes made
then attention will again be plotted
back or required back an interesting
thing or an interesting feature of this
attention or this task of attention is
something called a psychological
reflective period so you would have seen
that the premise of this whole thing is
that with attention with more practice
this attention becomes more or less
automatic things become automatic so the
question is are there tasks where no
matter how much practice you do it
doesn't become automatic are the tasks
which are there and so to prove that
principle something called psychological
refractory period was defined so
psychological refractory period the
existence of this period basically says
that there are certain kind of tasks or
there are certain kind of scenarios I no
matter how much practice you do with a
particular task what really happens is
that you tend to have no automaticity or
very less automatically into it so how
does the thing really work so
psychological reflective period refers
to the delay observed in execution of a
or the second of the two tasks which
must be in close temporal succession
with this task so basically I will be
finding the experiment and then let you
know what this particular thing is so
two tasks were actually given let's
first look at the pattern of how it
happens so there is a first task if two
tasks are there and so what we are
trying to see is what is the reason why
the two tasks are given and enough
practice is given in to both the task
where both the tasks are well done still
we do not see them being automatic why
this happens so we're seeing that so
let's say this is the first task now
there are three stars three stages to a
task one is the perceptual analysis one
is the response selection then the
response processing so if a job is given
to a task is given to the first thing is
you have to look at what the task is the
intuiting phase then select a response
to particular that task and then go
ahead and respond to it now if a second
task is given to you in
Succession right in this SOA means
stimulus onset and crony how close this
is a time dimension so del t how much
close these stimuluses are I'll explain
to you in the in the next figure and so
in a second while the first task is
being preceded a second task starts now
this particular slack which is there
which says that the delayed response
selection if a second task comes in when
the first task is being processed this
is called the psychology called
refractive period what does it really
mean it means that if two tasks are
presented to you and even if they are
very well learned tasks but as the first
task is being processed a second task is
also introduced what will really happen
that the second task will get delayed in
terms of processing and this delay that
you see is what is called the
psychological reflective period now in
the original experiment of this PRP what
happened is our stimulus was presented
as first stimulus was presented to
people and this stimulus was a stable
simple stimulus people had to hear a
tone so we had two tones we had a high
tone and we had a low tone and people
had to hear this tone and basically so
this is the hearing part so you hear
this tone and then categorize it whether
it is a height or not note on this is
stimulus number one a second stimulus
was given which was delayed a little bit
so once this stimulus was given once the
tone task started a little bit ad LT
time after that a second task was given
to you a second task was in terms of a
letter identification so an image was
presented to in front of you and what
you had to do is look at this image so
if an image of a was presented to you
what you had to do is look at this a so
basically this is the display you see an
a and when you see a letter vowel or a
consonant
you have to press a different button so
a button pad is given to you you have to
press the left button if it is a wobble
and the right button if it is a
consonant so two tasks are there one
task is the tone matching task so you
have to tell whether it is high or low
and when you and the other is a letter
identification task when you see a
letter you have to press a particular
button now what is the experimental
paradigm say so the experimental
paradigm says that if enough time if
delta t right the time between s 1 and s
2 is high then performance of the second
task doesn't require or happens
flawlessly second task proceeds as usual
but as you start narrowing this delta T
if you start bringing this delta T this
T or rather R instead of delta T at say
T here so T is the time difference
between s 1 and s 2 but as soon as you
start narrowing this T as soon as you
start presenting this s 1 and s 2 in
quick succession if the time difference
between presentation of this task s 1
and s 2 is high what would happen is
that response delay would happen which
means that response for the second task
will get delayed more and more and which
basically means that the response to the
first task hardly after the response to
the first task a certain delay will come
in before the response of the second
does coming so quickly understand the
paradigm of this 2 tasks are given to
you task 1 tone matching task 2 is
identifying images and so what happens
is as the difference between these two
tasks are more if the task 1 completes
and the second task starts after that no
delay is there or even even between if
it starts no delays there and so now
psychological refractory period but if
the first task and second task happen
near to simultaneous if first task is
started and just within a delta T time
or very less time after the start of the
first task a second task is reduce the
response to the second task delays and
delay is called the psychological
reflective period so this delta T or
this response this slack the time that
it takes for response are to to happen
is what is called the psychological
reflective period so a general
interpretation of the PRP effect assumed
the presence of a bottleneck when
initiating a response to stimuli now in
very simple words you detected a
stimulus and and are processing that
information while the second stimulus
comes along we aren't able to attend to
the second stimulus and that is what is
the psychological refractory period now
the question is why does PRP happen or
where is this bottleneck this delay the
water neck is the delay of which which
is there in this context the second task
so where is this delay coming from where
is this delay happening and so three
answers have been given by pal co19
pashler
1963 and was bachelor 1960 says three
stays that there are three
interpretations of it it could be at the
stage of presentation the second
stimulus what could happen is the
bottleneck have happens because the
second stage the presentation of the
second stimulus is very peak and so this
delay occurs because the presentation of
the second stimulus is in quick
succession or it could be the stage of
which a response is selected for the
first emulous so basically or it could
be at the stage of making a response so
three scenarios can exist where I have
as I said this is my stimulus
presentation this is my response
selection and this is my response for
stimulus one whereas for the second case
this is my s2 this is my response
selection to s2 and this is my response
to s2 so response to s1 and response to
s2 and there are three scenarios the
bottleneck can appear because of because
of the fact that this second stimulus
appears because the presentation second
stimulus or it could be because the
response selection of this happens and
so since the response selection has not
happened
a slack happens here or it could be
because of the response giving out of
the response or omitting the response
creates
this kind of a bottleneck which is there
and the most prominent example or most
prominent answer which has been given
the bachelor and on well foots theory is
that at the stage of response is
selected so what happens here is that at
the stage of selection of a response if
a second stimulus comes in if a second
stimulus comes in when the first
response are the first stimulus is still
being processed a response of it is
being selected what will happen is you
will observe psychological reflective
period but if the response has already
been selected but the response has not
been given in those cases the
psychological refractory period will not
occur think of it in terms of example
you go to a bank teller who is working
on a job so cause you so customer one
comes in and asks a question now as soon
as the question is put into this person
this bank teller is searches for an
answer now a second customer comes in
and asks the question psychological
reflective period will only occur if the
second person the second customer puts a
question and this question interferes or
comes in or is appears at the time when
the bank teller or when the bank person
is still searching for an answer is
doing a response selection still
searching for an answer for the cost
customer in case the bank teller has
already found the answer and it is only
the response that he has to give no kind
of slack will happen and both responses
will be automatic you could answer to
both the persons at the same point of
time but then in cases where the person
the bank teller is still working at an
answer and you put your question quickly
what really happens is that second
stimulus get processed delayed get
processed at a later point of time and
the delay that it takes from response
selection for a small selection of
stimulus one - there is - the response
selection to the static of response
election of item two is what is called
the psychological defective period so in
very simple terms the time slack which
happens or the time lag which happens
for the processing of a second stimulus
when s1 and represent s2 are presented
very
in equal time that and that happening
because the response election for stage
1 or simulus 1 is still happening and s
2 arrives at a time when s ones response
election is still being taking place is
what is called psychological reflective
period or psychological reflective
period in very very simple terms is a
delay on response to stimulus 2 because
stimulus 1 is still getting processed
but if the processing has happened if
the answer has is present then
psychological refractory period will not
occur so in this section in this
particular class we looked at what is
autumn ization what does the factors
fertilization how to test out
normalization what is controlled
processing and automate and automatic
processing in attention and we also
looked at what is called how attention
is a part of perception how attention
plays apart into perception we looked at
attentional capture and also something
called
psychological refractory period which
means that even if two jobs even if two
tasks are very automatic if it is well
done task
still the idea that one task comes in
quick succession or it comes quickly
after the other task and the response
selection or or the kind of answer to
the first task has not been selected
from from the memory then it creates so
basically psychological refractory
period is a memory related phenomena and
so that creates a time delay in response
of the second stimulus and that is what
is called the psychological reflective
period so this this is an end to the
section on attention will meet again
with a new section on memory thank you
[Music]
you